nous questionner ne fait pas partie de
votre travail
vous êtes ici uniquement pour la
surveiller
il est prévu que la surveillance dure
deux semaines
nous vous proposons des créneaux de 8
heures il n'y aura pas de concertation
entre vous deux
[Musique]
le 14e jour vous reviendrez et vous
ferez chacune votre tour une
présentation de ce que vous avez
constaté puis-je vous demander messieurs
personne ne m'a dit précisément ce qui
n'allait pas chez cette fille
ne s'alimente pas
savoir depuis combien de temps la
fillette n'a pas pris de nourriture
cela va faire quatre mois
c'est impossible
lève les bras et ouvre grand les yeux tu
te sens nerveuse pourquoi je me sentir
énervé
tu connais les dangers d'un jeune
prolongé Anna je n'ai pas besoin de
manger je vis de la manne
le pain du ciel et comment est-ce que tu
te sens rassasié anna est en danger
docteur c'est une comédienne
elle a été choisie
est-ce que tu te sens bien au fond de
toi
très bien mon père
comment une étrangère peut-elle
s'interposer entre une enfant et sa
famille
pour découvrir la vérité
de mettre un terme à cette surveillance
c'était une erreur de faire venir une
affirmière Anglaise de surcroît
nous comprenez
n'importe qui peut être choisi
[Musique]